on to anderson cooper who's opening up
about his sexual awakening oh boy yeah
while appearing on a radio end this is
so cute from the historic stonewall inn
in new york city on friday anderson told
andy cohen about how meeting a shirtless
richard gere at the age of 11 helped him
realize he was gay
when i was 11 my mom's a friend of my
mom's uh
a photographer named paul jasmine uh
came with his boyfriend i guess his
boyfriend who had a diamond embedded in
his front tooth which i thought was
interesting which was way before anyone
was doing that madonna yes yeah we're
done in 1970s did you have a fake ass
and they took me to see richard gere in
bent which are you kidding me when you
were 11. yeah if anyone doesn't know
about the play ben it's about two gay
guys in the concentration camp i mean
the opening
day it is the gayest thing you can
imagine and starring richard gere wow
and this was richard gere in 1977 prime
looking for mr goodbar he was so
beautiful and i'm there my mom didn't go
it's just me and my mom's two gay
friends okay and i'm watching this thing
and literally the opening scene of ben
like there's a guy in bed who's just it
was picked up some guy the night before
and the guy he's picked up uh gets out
of bed completely naked and then puts on
his ss stormtrooper uniform oh my god
and i just remember being like
oh my god i'm gay like this is
[Laughter]
i'm totally gay
and
and afterward that paul jasmine was
friends with richard gere because paul
jasmine took the pictures for american
gigolo and we go backstage and richard
gere is shirtless in his dressing room
and i i was i never heard i was so
i couldn't speak i i didn't and i had my
play bill and i wanted to get him an
autograph but i was too
i just couldn't stop staring his chest
and uh so fast forward to i don't know
10 years ago i was interviewing richard
gere and i took out the playbill and i
told i had the playbill still and i told
him the whole story and i had him sign
it wow yeah he was very tickled with it
that
is high
now i'm gonna put you on the spot okay
who was your sexual awakening okay mine
is a little bit strange i'm gonna i'm
gonna forewarn you um so it's from the
scream movie and it was i know i know
maybe this says something about my
psyche but it was the there was this
moment where like the killer was
revealed and it was like he had that
like sort of 90s middle part i can't
remember what that was which yes
and it was like a little bit of sort of
blood on his face and he sort of like
licked the i know and i don't know what
it was but at that moment i was like
there it is
i don't know why there was this it was
just sort of like bad boy energy
less the like killing portion of it
obviously but yeah the sort of bad boy
like 90s energy and like yeah now that
it's like really coming back onto tick
tock i'm like okay
i interviewed him once in vancouver
very sexy man just say it thank you that
was that was interesting yeah yeah yeah
for me
growing up
devon sawwa come on
casper yeah now and then
so cute that was it and that was it and
i was like oh i think i like boys yeah
that was the funniest
me so i was telling you the story like
um so much facts of life okay and there
was a character named george on it and
then just this year i realized that was
george clooney i mean george clooney is
a good one
yeah yeah i like tall guys
i don't know
i know i was like
i'm wearing stilettos does that count
my husband is six three so six three
there you go leave us your comments who
is your sexual awakening
all right christian bale has revealed
that he has it did we do the story yeah
we've already talked about christianity
okay so christian bill um thank you uh
so moving on we are okay here we go so
sexual awakening anymore yeah did we get
anyone that revealed any
no i love my hair do you girl okay oh my
god oh thank you i interviewed him okay
um is this where we're starting no we're
gonna go we're
we've already talked about man batman
and robin is so campy though so i loved
it i still love it mr freeze yes
batgirl i was a huge alicia silverstone
fan growing up okay yeah motorcycle yeah
how dare i not mention christina ricci
oh i have been a christina richie fan
and i will follow christina ricci until
that's the one the day i leave this
planet yeah love love love love love